comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV and starting
now on book TV our coverage of the 2017
Rancho Mirage writers festival from last
weekend in California today we have
several authors including former Senator
Barbara Boxer Pulitzer Prize winning
author Lawrence Wright humorists Dave
berry and Carl Hiaasen historian Douglas
Brinkley and more first up David Akers
talks about his book the lucky years how
to thrive in the brave new world of
health thank you all very much it's
certainly a privilege to be here when
Helene and Jamie call you come so I am
here so about seven years ago I wrote my
first book and I was so excited I spent
all this time thinking of the title and
the title I came up with was what is
health because to me was the key
question I didn't know what health was
was it how you look was it how you feel
was it how long you live how well you
live what was health how do you optimize
on a parameter well you don't have a
parameter upon which to optimize so I
sent it to the publisher and about a
week later the publisher called and said
David
Steve Jobs just called and changed the
title of your book I said he did what
and I called up Steve and I said what
are you doing he goes David you can't
put the word health in the title it's a
bad word in our country as soon as you
say health people's eyes glaze over it's
like chewing cardboard he said when you
say health people think of Brussels
sprouts
he said you need something optimistic
declarative and he came up with the
title the end of illness and so this is
what Steve was alluding to right this
quote from Mark Twain the only way you
keep your health is he what you don't
want drink what you don't like and do
what you'd rather not well I will show
you today that's not the case I'm gonna
offend some of you I'm gonna take away
things that you've been leaning on and
show you there's very little data behind
them I'm gonna push you but these aren't
my opinions these are data and I'm going
to show you the data about the things we
do and where I think we should be going
going forward and so you know our
country is about being bigger and better
so if I take a seven-year-old and I give
him a shot at growth hormone
a month later their friends are gonna
come up there and go you look like a
million bucks you look 10 years younger
it works right it makes you look better
makes you feel a little bit better on
average it takes 16 years off your life
but you look better today so the
question is what is your metric do you
want to look good today or do you want
to play with your grandchildren tomorrow
you know there's a population in Ecuador
that are short stature and they have a
mutation on the growth hormone receptor
there's almost no cancer and no diabetes
in that population yet we try to be
bigger and so the key thing is identify
each of you what you want your goal to
be you know the other big topic if
things like testosterone we hear on the
radio every day ads for loti so in the
largest study done looking at people
with low teen giving them testosterone
they found something interesting when
they did that no increase in muscle mass
no crease in libido no increase in how
the people felt felt but dramatic
increase in cardiovascular events and
death and by the way death is a bad side
effect for a drug
so again I challenge you is whenever you
do something and that's gonna be with
the resounding message over and over is
asked why and to say where is the data
in what we're doing because testosterone
for lo T there were over 200 million
prescriptions written last year for it
and so this is an experiment that
changed everything
so in 1950s in 1952 a woman named Wanda
Ruth Lunsford in New York City published
her only paper in science who's actually
kicked out of science what Wanda did was
she took an old rat and a young rat and
she put him to sleep and she tied their
skin together so after about a day the
blood supply's joined three weeks later
she looked in that old rat the gray hair
had turned brown again there were new
neurons growing in the brain the heart
beats stronger and the muscles were
bigger wanda claims she reversed aging
well people called her dracula people
called her frankenstein and she was
pushed out of science well last year
three separate laboratories one at
university of california san francisco
one at stanford and one at harvard
repeated Wanda's experiment and it
worked and what they showed is at age 25
in you and i our stem cells go to sleep
and there are proteins now that can
reawaken them that can turn on these
stem cells and have the potential of
reversing some of the maladies of aging
so the clinical trial ongoing now in
Boston in the elderly who have fractured
a hip using these proteins to accelerate
healing there's a clinical trial ongoing
now in Northern California and people
with cognitive decline to hopefully
increase neurogenesis new neurons we're
doing it in cancer you know cancer in
children is 90% curable once you turn 25
that same cancer is incurable so if I
could convince the body it's younger
maybe we can have a bigger impact on
cancer
and so our goal is to live into our
ninth or tenth decade the very simple
way we do it is we avoid disease I'm
going to show you some remarkable ways
of treating disease but clearly the
easiest way to do it is to avoid disease
the paradox is if you avoid disease and
you live into your 90s healthcare costs
go down and not up 83 is the magic age
in our country where if you live to it
and you get sick we don't do these crazy
heroic things that don't benefit the
individual like I see you long stays
ventilator and other things we let
people die with dignity 1954 was the
last year in the United States of
America you could die with the cause of
deaths on her death certificate
edge ever since then we need another
cause of death Alzheimers heart disease
cancer I want to go back to dying of old
age and I'll show you how we can do it
so I argue that we screwed up in the
1920s one experiment screwed up medicine
for 90 plus years one single experiment
and what they did in this experiment is
they had two groups there were 12 people
in total half of them had a large cut on
their leg and they took a piece of bread
they dipped that piece of bread and
water and they wrapped the bread around
the leg half of them had a large cut and
they left it open to the air well the
people with the bread on their leg heal
twice as fast right
that bread made mold the mold made
penicillin and it spawned something
called germ theory germ theory said as
soon as you know what you're up against
you know how to fix it you recognize
that bacteria in the microscope you know
exactly what antibiotic to give it and
they are right the problem is every
other human disease Alzheimer's heart
disease cancer are from within and not
from without and so if you're going to
drive from Palm Springs to Los Angeles
and you take apart a car look at every
piece of the car it doesn't tell you how
long it takes to get there you forgot to
look at the traffic the weather the
bladder size of the driver how much
caffeine the driver drank
they all matter but in the field of
medicine we keep looking at the car and
we forget everything else and so the
challenge is not to look at the cell but
to look at the system to me diseases are
verbs and not nouns york answering your
heart disease in your alzheimerís one
doesn't get cancer it's something the
body does and that's a radically
different way of thinking about both
disease and health and I'm gonna show
you what it means but first I want to
tell you a story and I have to apologize
in advance before this story because the
character will offend some of you but I
think the message of the story
transcends the character so in 1997 I
was a trainee at sloan-kettering Cancer
Center in New York and I was working
with his great cancer doc and there was
a kid at the time who was 25 years old
who had germ cell tumor in the brain the
lung and the liver and he had gone to
all the great cancer centers in the
country and they had all looked him in
the eye and says you know you're the son
of a single mother you've got a disease
that doesn't respond to chemotherapy
spend your last few months at home with
her doctors actually said be a man this
kid heard about an experiment this is
before Google you know nowadays you
could search everything you know what's
going on but pre-google there was such a
time pre Google this kid heard about an
experiment where a doctor put two
platinum electrodes in a gel and said to
cancer cells like electricity or not
well turns out the cancer cells didn't
care about the electricity but some of
the platinum the same thing on my
wedding band leached off and killed some
of the cells so this kid said hey give
me intravenous platinum well experiments
were done and he was given platinum
intravenously while year and a half
later he won his first of seven now
contested towards the Front's so this
was Lance Armstrong so lance and I sat
on a TEDTalk stage several years ago
this is before the scandal we sat down
and he looked me in the eye goes aigis
fifteen years ago I was given a death
sentence
now I'm alive and well how to platinum
work I thought about it for a minute
looked him back in the eye and I said I
have no freaking idea platinum changed
you so the cancer didn't want to grow it
was such a powerful message to me again
I'm not here to target that cancer cell
I'm here to change the individual so the
cancer didn't want to grow you know this
is a clinical trial well this is a think
of it this way we have inputs to our
body the input is who your parents are
your genetics what you eat where you
live who you marry how you work and the
output is how you feel well that middle
state function throughout history it's
been hidden and in fact today I will
show you for the first time a picture of
it but the problem with complex emergent
systems is they're almost impossible to
understand yet we can control things we
don't understand you know the climate
modeler doesn't go out every day and go
up 20,000 feet and measure the wind
speed of the temperature he or she looks
at the shape of the clouds and it tells
them what's going to happen
I want doctors to be more like climate
modelers than biologists going forward
and I'll show you what that means so
there's a trial done that we're part of
when we took women with premenopausal
breast cancer so these are young women
with breast cancer and classically we
treat and then we wait for the cancer to
occur in this case we took the women and
half of them we gave a drug for
osteoporosis a drug that builds bone and
half we gave placebo and when we looked
we prevented recurrence of the cancer by
over 40% why because breast cancer
metastasizes to bone so if you change
the soil this seed doesn't grow if you
change the soil the seed doesn't grow so
one of the biggest survival advantages
in a cancer clinical trial was a drug
that didn't even touch the cancer that
was a powerful message to me that again
my job is to change the system it's not
necessarily to target a disease cell and
so take what I say somewhat with a grain
of
salt right on the same profession that
do this and this and I love this one
lady with a lamp on the same profession
that told people 35 years ago eat
margarine not butter and if you look at
the epidemiologic data we killed
millions of people by making these bold
declaratory statements with no data at
all behind them so what I want to do now
is go through some of the things aspects
of our life on a daily basis and say
where's the data and let's start to look
at it well the first is an amazing study
that was published in the 1953 the
british medical journal Lancet by a man
named Jeremiah Morris and this was a
paper that wasn't referenced for 50
years back then there were no health
privacy laws so he went it to the
British Transit Authority which was an
organization with 26,000 employees half
of them were the bus drivers that satton
drove those double-decker buses and sat
90 percent of the day and half were the
ticket takers that walked up and down
the double-decker buses both of the
groups weighed the same smoke the same
and lived in the same socio-economic
environment yet dramatically lower heart
disease and cancer in the bus drivers
you know we've become a society of bus
drivers
I mean lowering the ticket takers I'm
sorry but we've become a society of bus
drivers right the richer you are the
more bathrooms in your house so you even
have to walk room to room to go to the
bathroom the more important you are in
your company they're closer your parking
spaces to your desk our bodies were
designed to move and we need to respect
that the lymphatics that control your
immune system have no muscle in their
wall so it's the rhythmic contraction of
the muscles in your legs when you walk
that actually make your body work its
movement over time equal south and I
love this st. an audience that's sitting
down sitting for five hours a day is
equivalent on a health basis as smoking
a pack and a quarter of cigarettes
sitting for five hours is the same of
smoking a pack and a quarter of
cigarettes and yet we sit and
yeah when you go to your doctor this is
one of the biggest risk factors for
disease do they have a data element that
reflects that do they say to you how
often do you move every hour the answer
uniformly is no you know I was shocked
when I got one of those devices and I
looked how much I moved during the day I
was a lot more sedentary than I thought
so I have a treadmill desk in my office
so the two hours a day I do email I'm
actually walking at a very slow pace
takes about a week or two to get used to
I have one of those headsets that kind
of look like an air traffic controller
so when I'm on phone calls I can walk
around the office
instead of sitting at my desk I try to
take at least one walking meeting a day
you know when I would go up to see Steve
Jobs every time we would go for a walk
and we would go for a walk and he was a
David there two reasons to go for a walk
first is the health benefit we all know
that then he said is if you're gonna do
a business negotiation with somebody and
you go for a walk and at the corner you
know if you're gonna turn left or right
and they don't it gives you an advantage
in the negotiations so he thought of
every little angle to everything but we
need to redesign our lives you know we
talked and we blowin lis terms this
building is LEED certified for the
environment well whose certifying
buildings for health nobody should have
a printer at their desk they should get
up and walk to the other end of the
office every child every classroom
should be as far away from possible as
the last classroom there's a reason the
Apple watch every hour taps you on the
wrist if you haven't moved enough it's
to remind you to get up and move you
know what's amazing is in that same
study they looked at profession and rate
of death so the worse were the
hairdresser's because they stood in one
spot or the Secretary's because they sat
all day the best were the gardener's and
the coal miners because they were moving
the coal miners were the best so there's
actual data that if you add an hour of
walking per week every hour you add you
live longer simple as that
walking equals longer life very very
simple ever
everybody wants to take a pill to buy
something it's all in there just walking
you know the amazing thing is in the
state of California they eliminated
three periods of exercise I mean of
academics and replaced it with exercise
and the test scores the kids went up and
not down you know there's an amazing
entrepreneur in California who founded
two companies he found a one company
Chucky Cheese and another company called
Atari this is the guy who had two
employees named Steve working for him
who one day said you know we're making
these game systems that hooked to
televisions let's put it all into one
and he says get out of here it makes no
sense well those two Steve's left and
formed a small company called Apple but
this guy did a trial where he showed up
a child exercises for 15 minutes he or
she will retain almost 20% more
knowledge for five hours that's good too
great right there so will you want your
kids your grandchildren see to be the
best they can be
morning before school have them go run
around the block once or twice that
simple thing will have an impact on
their academic performance so this is an
amazing picture it's an amazing study
that taught me a lot about medicine so
in the 1950s you know today we're taught
that if you have appendicitis 24/7 it's
got to come out doctors are called get
out of bed right now there's a pen
decided case in the emergency room you
go in you take it out whether you're a
patient or a doctor this is the medical
emergency well this is a picture in the
1960s of a Russian explorer who was a
doctor who went to Antarctica and he got
appendicitis and he's taking out his own
appendix so an amazing thing if you
think about it well two years ago in
Europe they did a study where they
looked at a people with appendicitis and
they questioned it and they said listen
we've been doing this for a hundred
years why don't we give him antibiotics
and see what happens well when they did
that 70 percent of the people and
they're over 300 thousand of these done
in the United States years 70 percent of
the people didn't need surgery at all
the other 30% had no increased side
effects by waiting
so all of a sudden we question one of
the dominant surgical procedures in our
country and what we showed is it wasn't
even necessary the amazing thing is the
rate of appendicitis Tamizh taking out
appendices since this was published and
today hasn't changed at all so doctors
are stubborn and pigheaded like myself
it takes on average 15 years for 50% of
doctors to adopt a new technology so we
are slow
we are slow to change and slow to learn
I believe medicine will change from the
ground up
not the top down you will push your
doctor to make change he or she will not
find it by reading a medical journal if
you go in in question they will think
and that can have change so the change
in medicine will happen with all of us
not just at the physician sign you know
there's a notion in our country vitae is
life therefore vitamins are good for you
so when we looked at women who took
multivitamins versus women who didn't in
general women to take multivitamins are
healthier they're skinnier there's less
high blood pressure or less diabetes but
when they took multivitamins there was a
higher death rate than the women who
didn't so that was an interesting
question and certainly cause for alarm
and so further studies were done so the
first was vitamin D so these are the
headlines from the internet about
vitamin D it does everything right heart
disease cancer stroke you name it how
many of you are taking vitamin D or
calcium and vitamin D so more than half
of you so let's look at the data
remember we as humans we evolved a
mechanism so we don't get too much
vitamin D at once
it's called tanning right the reason we
can is because too much vitamin D isn't
good for the body so the first thing we
did was look what are vitamin D levels
in the country so 75 percent of people
in the United States of America are low
in vitamin D 97 percent of
african-americans in the country of
Canada they had an outlaw of 80 vitamin
D testing because it was 11% of their
entire countries laboratory budget
an epidemic of testing you know if
there's this really new epidemic of
vitamin D being low hip fractures are
actually going down and not up which is
an interesting observation and so if you
look if you took women who are 70 and
older and gave them vitamin D to raise
their level the rate of bone fractures
goes up 26% not down it goes up not down
so if you think about it you have
vitamin D you've got the sensor which is
the receptor and you've got a bunch of
signaling molecules when you measure one
node of a network what does it mean I
don't know who define what normal was I
didn't come with an instruction manual
when I was born I don't know about you
but when you take a high dose of vitamin
D which is a pill that sensor gets down
regulated and the signaling is different
so women who take calcium and vitamin D
there have been now three large studies
with over 20,000 never have there ever
been a benefit shown so the US
Preventive task force which is our
nation's most conservative group says
nobody in the country should be taking
calcium or calcium and vitamin D because
there's never been a benefit shown lots
of stomach upset
lots of kidney stones too high dose
increases bone fracture never was there
a clinical benefit shown in a normal
individual so what vitamins are is
something the body can't synthesize
enough of but how many of you have
friends with rickets or beriberi or
scurvy I've never met anybody and so the
challenge is is these compounds which
are marketed beautifully and we're told
to take and many times the doctor tells
you to take it I want you to go back and
say where is the data that it will
actually benefit me and so take vitamin
e MN there was a study done and it cost
a two hundred and sixty million dollars
to the taxpayers where they randomized
with the vitamin E and placebo and after
year three they had to stop the study
because there was a 17% increase in
prostate cancer in the men who took the
vitamin E so the most common non skin
cancer in men increased by 17% and yet
we all do it this is the same vitamin E
that's in a multivitamin we all take it
and so the challenge is to say why you
know there have been 63 studies in the
United States with over 10,000 people
randomized to multivitamin or placebo
none zero zilch have ever shown a
benefit in a normal individual man or
woman ever so the naysayers say well you
know these are studies only done for 20
or 30 years disease happens over an
entire lifetime
so take people with more common disease
smokers and non-smokers so they did and
they gave them vitamin A and
beta-carotene two big antioxidants and
what they found was dramatic increase in
lung cancer and death rate in the people
who took these we spend more on vitamins
the United States of America than we do
in all of medical research by the way we
spend more on potato chips in the US of
A than we do on cancer research so an
amazing concept here right is potential
for significant harm yet we allow people
to do it I'm gonna make a statement that
some of you will like and some of you
won't but we have a right in our country
to do what we want you can smoke you
could be as fat as you want you could
sit around all day and then society has
the obligation of paying for the health
care ramifications of your behavior at
some point that has to stop we have to
take responsibility for our own health
Michael Dell who is the CEO of Dell
computer had over a hundred thousand
employees and one day he said you know
I'm gonna change our health plan and I'm
gonna make it so that I'm gonna charge
more for the smokers three times as much
because that's what it costs us and why
should a non-smokers subsidize a smoker
he got pushed back people were pissed
off and some people even quit other
people cheered he doesn't change it and
he actually gave a discount if you
didn't smoke and nobody objected so it's
a very interesting phenomena
carrot-and-stick but it's a notion that
we need to start to take responsibility
in the Affordable Care Act something
called Obamacare they used to be in
place last week
one of the provisions is that you could
differentially charge health insurance
in every state in our country based on
behavior and that's one of the powerful
things in there is to incentivize people
to do the right thing it's at some point
we have to take a stand here we allow
things to happen we allow products to be
marketed you know Mayor Bloomberg got up
and he said no large sodas in New York
City no trans fats in New York City and
people argued nanny state good nanny
state bad nobody argued that trans fats
were good for you nobody the argued
large sodas were good for you
and if you look at the data whether you
were fat or skinny short or tall
behavior changed so with discourse comes
understanding in order to get normative
behavior change you need leadership and
we are sorely lacking leadership in the
health space in the United States when
the greatest health leader over the last
decade is the former mayor of New York
City you know there's a problem in our
space health and food represents 31
percent of the United States economy yet
I challenge you you know who's been the
Surgeon General over the last four years
nobody will know who's been the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
very few people know we don't have
leaders in the space and as you know by
going on the internet there's a lot of
noise out there you can find anything
you want well a way to get around that
noise very simply is to have true
leadership to be filters and that's
something we need badly in our country
so this is a piece I wrote a couple
years ago in the New York Times that
turned out to be the second most
downloaded article of the year in The
Times it was about a pill that was 2433
years old that if you take it every day
you reduce not the incidence but the
death rate of cancer by 30% heart
disease by 22% and stroke by 17% it was
about a pill a day that cost about three
dollars a year it's called a baby
aspirin we we did a scientific study at
USC with Dana Goldman and what we showed
is that if everybody in the country took
a baby aspirin who should we have
900,000 extra people alive in 20 years
and we would save over 700
billion dollars in healthcare costs yet
the problem is we don't take it it's too
cheap
nobody's marketing it nobody's pushing
it nobody's promoting it so less than
20% of people who should take it
actually take this pill this pill a day
that reduces inflammation and that's one
of the key things on disease is
inflammation it's at the root of heart
disease cancer and Alzheimer's and what
we've learned is that what this pill who
Epocrates described over 2400 years ago
when he said you take the bark of the
willow tree and chew it and pain and
fever go away this was aspirin you know
the CEO in Davos I was at last week the
CEO of one of the great companies came
up to me and said you know they have a
were the largest maker of aspirin in the
world we did it first in the 1920s
aren't you proud of us I go are you
serious where's Generation 2.0 where's
the next one without side-effects
where's one that's ten percent better
you're standing on your laurels for 90
years come on and obviously he went with
his tail between his legs and walked
away but this is a remarkable
observation you know there's a study
that was done at Oxford they have these
are studies and hundreds of thousands of
people over 200,000 people randomized
for over 20 years and what they showed
if you took the aspirin for six and a
half years metastatic cancer is down by
36% adenocarcinoma that's breast
prostate lung ovary down by 46% a baby
aspirin a day will reduce pancreatic
cancer by 60%
these are staggering numbers from a drug
that doesn't cost very much at all you
know there's another class of drugs
called statins which are the lipitor
like drugs lipitor Crestor those class
of drugs they were developed to lower
cholesterol but it turns out they were
totally different mechanism they reduce
inflammation so if you take somebody
with a normal cholesterol and put them
on one of these pills you'll delay heart
attack and stroke by over a decade and
reduce the incidence of cancer and so
the biggest drug in the history of
medicine we got the mechanism wrong
interesting there but again hitting
inflammation so two ways to modulate
down inflammation dramatic lowering of
disease both this lipitor
I mean there's lipitor Lake drug statins
and aspirin well people say edgers are
pushing drugs from the pharmaceutical
company no I'm pushing progress how much
does it cost for a 90-day supply of
lipitor without health insurance the
United States plus nine dollars nine
dollars for a 90-day supply without
health insurance so this is not
expensive but the impact on human health
on society on each of us can be dramatic
so switching gears now well in 1974
Monsanto and their annual report
estimated a hundred and fifty million
dollars to sequence one gene well now
routinely if a patient sees me I can
sequence hundreds of genes overnight for
less than $10 you know when I launched
the first book Bill Weir who was a
Nightline anchor came in we did five
night lines in a row he came in and live
on tv.we sequences DNA
he's a 41 year old healthy fit guy two
young kids and we found out that he was
higher risk for heart disease so based
on that we walked him over to a heart
scan and did a heart scan live on TV and
we showed that he had a blockage a
lesion and one of the big arteries in
his heart at the time he called it the
story that saved his life and so the
next day people argue well you should in
the screen he wasn't eligible for a
cardiac scan I go first of all cardiac
scan cost about $90 and you saying he
wasn't eligible but your criteria wrong
because he was positive so we have to
start to use technologies like this to
identify who's at risk
- hopefully intervene early and change
behavior
it worked in him and it will work in
many people you know this is a company I
founded now nine years ago we've spit
into a tube we sequence your DNA and we
see what diseases can happen in your
lifetime to me knowledge is power every
one of them are delay Abell
or interventional and the challenge is
to know what you're up against the
challenge is to know where to put your
focus the challenge is to get you to
change behavior you know one of the
biggest problems we have in health is
how do I get you to do something today
that's gonna help you 10 20 30 years
down the road there's delay
gratification
how do I get a 30 year old to change the
behavior that help them when they're 60
hard to do so the one thing about
genetics is you can't blame your parents
for everything is that about half is you
it's what you eat is the medicine should
take you to your behavior and you are in
control of that there are very few genes
that are destiny right we all have heard
about one BRCA the breast cancer gene
you know about three years ago and
Angelina Jolie announced quite
heroically I have the gene for breast
cancer so that day the New York Times
asked me to write a companion piece and
what we wrote about was in the 90s there
was a team of researchers that was
tasked with 25 million dollars from the
government to identify this gene well
they did so in the Mormons because the
Mormons wanted to be buried in the
church in Salt Lake City and obviously
they all couldn't fit so they put their
hair which was a part of them along with
her histories and so there was DNA going
back a hundred years so in that
population the gene was identified who
was licensed to a company that went
bankrupt another company bought the
assets and they charged six thousand
dollars for this test so I called a
predatory practice and monopolistic how
dare a company charges six thousand
dollar ransom for a woman to look at her
own DNA the company you know back had
all this whole PR campaign and then
three months later I got a call from
somebody on the Supreme Court Justice of
the United States who said David later
today we're going to announce you could
no longer patent a gene in our country
and we have the piece you wrote above
our desk aren't you proud of us we have
democratized DNA I said I'm happy you
did that but you're 14 years too late
because in those 14 years over a hundred
thousand women died because they
couldn't afford to look at their own DNA
well since that change in the Supreme
Court came out it's now about a hundred
dollars to have that test done the
challenge is and what I'm going to show
you some of the progress is that are
happening now is how do we get the legal
system to catch up and move at a pace
that doesn't take over a decade the
ethical system the moral system we're at
a time I called the lucky years in my
new book we're at a time where pace and
progress is happen
literally every week the problem is
we're not ready for it as a society so
in 1976 if you thought you were pregnant
your spouse thought they were pregnant
your child thought they were pregnant
your girlfriend
we took a tube of blood this test could
only be done in a hospital we injected a
rabbit 5 days later we killed the rabbit
and if the rabbits ovaries were enlarged
you were pregnant that was the state of
the art in 1976
well 1977 along came a company called
Warner Shulkin and for nine dollars they
had the first protein or proteomic test
will rabbit to the world rejoiced and at
the same time we radically changed
maternal health and Nenana health from
one single protein in the blood well we
now through technology have the ability
of looking at all the proteins in the
body and this is it this is the state of
the system I told you a while back I
would show you this is a drop of blood
going through a superconducting magnet
where we can look at all the proteins in
the blood this is the conversation in
the body and for the first time now
through technology we can listen in in
fact in that first book of mine the end
of illness when the book came out it was
a different cover than I had planned and
again I called that publisher and Steve
Jobs that put this on the cover because
it spoke to him last week I was in Davos
at the World Economic Forum with yo-yo
ma who I got to know yo-yo because he
used to play music for Steve Jobs in his
living room
yo-yo is converting this conversation
into music now and so we've been have we
our body has been talking forever but we
now can actually listen in and we can
start to see what's happening a moment
in time the way I think of it is this if
you're in front of two Chinese
restaurants and look at the ingredient
list they're exactly the same you taste
the food one could be great and one
could be bad well DNA is your ingredient
list protein or what the food tastes
like well everybody always says what's
next so what's next is what we call the
microbiome so it turns out you have 10
far more bacteria in you than human
cells in you there's 10 for more
bacterial DNA in each of us than human
DNA
these bacteria they control our
metabolism what food we absorb many
things about us so an amazing study was
done last year where they took 20 year
olds and they gave them any of the six
fda-approved artificial sweeteners
because when they came out they were the
greatest food in the world right they
hit our sweet tooth if they weren't
absorbs there was zero calories they
were the perfect food well after two
weeks every single one of them had
markers of diabetes or prediabetes in
their blood they said hey that's
interesting
then they gave them antibiotics followed
by the artificial sweeteners no markers
of diabetes at all
so what the artificial sweeteners did is
they changed the dominant bacteria in us
and that pushed our system toward
diabetes in fact I've been to large two
clinical trials with artificial
sweeteners to try to lose weight and
they didn't work and the investigators
had the gall at the end of it to say
well people were a fat cheat and they
eat food without telling the people in
the trial it's know they got the science
wrong pretty amazing is that all of a
sudden we have a new dimension to you
and too high you know there was a study
done at Cleveland Clinic where they did
gastric banding which is where they give
us something to make the stomach smaller
these are people 350 pounds and above
they all have diabetes after 20 days
there's no diabetes and yet nobody
started to lose weight yet so what
happens with that somewhat barbaric
surgery is it actually changes which
bacteria are dominant and it fixes
diabetes and it makes them overtime lose
weight so going forward we're gonna
treat diabetes obesity by changing the
microbiome rather than doing these crazy
surgeries or other medicines we're gonna
change the system so the other big
advance in these lucky years is what we
call big data you know one of the
studies came out showing that if you had
ovarian cancer and you happen to be on a
beta blocker which is an inexpensive
generic drug for blood pressure
you live four and a half years longer
than if you weren't we would have never
known that from biology but big data
showed us big data showed us and one of
the biggest studies ever done that in
Europe the closer you live to an airport
to higher the rate of brain decline as
you get older implying that our brain
needs quiet at night when we sleep so I
have a hundred and fifty pound dog
that's no
and sleeps in our bedroom and I can't
bear to kick her out so I wear those
orange foam earplugs at night and my
brain gets too quiet
it needs staggering observation so
whether you live in a city whether you
have noisy neighbors whether you live
next to a river your brain needs quiet
at night and we have to respect that you
know we learned wrote a piece on this in
the New York Times about these premises
the prilosec these acid blockers we all
take what we know now from big data
because the clinical trial to approve
them was a year or two well we know that
from big data is that if you take them
rate of alzheimerís goes up rate of
heart disease goes up over time we would
have never known that unless we had big
data to look at so we're in this era of
big data where we're now have the
ability every time you go to your
doctor's office your data can be part of
the solution not part of the problem at
the same day time we have to work on
healthcare security of information there
have been five hospitals over the last
year that hijackers came in and took
over the data at a hospital and were
actually paid ransom for the hospitals
to get it back what will happen one day
soon is that Helene Galen shows up in an
emergency room and she has an infection
on her arm the doctors look at her
medical record
give her an antibiotic in an hour later
she's dead no offense because what
happened is somebody went in and changed
her medical record and took away an
allergy think about it how you could
change the course of a political
election of a CEO of a company the stock
price of a company by changing medical
records giving them a disease changing
what they have if someone broke into
blue cross that has over 300 people they
are full-time on their IT staff and
actually took over a hundred million
records think of your local doctor how
many people are on their IT staff the
other big technology to come out is
called CRISPR
and I know you were all so excited last
year when they named science magazine
every year names molecule of the year
well last year CRISPR was molecule of
the year was very exciting this is a
molecule that was
surgical precision can change one of the
three billion letters of our DNA code so
for the first time ever we can edit our
DNA code so it's certainly exciting in
China they've already changed the DNA
code of an embryo so conceivably you can
correct diseases like sickle cell anemia
you can re-engineer t-cells to attack
cancer you can do all kinds of things
but you can also make a child blonde or
blue or eye taller faster and smarter
potentially with the technology like
this well the first foods using this
technology are already on the market
they don't have to be labeled because
they're not genetically modified there's
no new gene they're just changing the
genes that are there at the same time in
South America they use this technology
to attack the biggest killer in the
history of the world more people by a
factor of 10 have died from mosquitoes
than in every war in the world combined
right between malaria between the zika's
between all of the mosquito-borne
illnesses mosquitoes have killed more
people than every war in the world and
so they use this technology to make it
so that when a male and female have sex
they actually die and in these towns in
South America they've been able to limit
over 90% of the mosquitoes in those
towns
well environmental seeing that it's a
it's a no way you can't do that who
knows what it's gonna do the frog
population well if you've ever seen a
child born with almost no brain and no
skull which would happen with Zika you
might think a little bit differently and
Zika obviously was a big issue the
summer it will come back next year we
won't have a vaccine to over a year from
now
Zika stays in the mosquito when it's
dormant so in the offseason and we'll
see it come back and it will be again in
the headlines starting in April of this
year you know one of the big positives
that happen is what we call
immunotherapy so about a year and a half
ago I did the morning show and we talked
about Jimmy Carter our president who
heroically said I have skin cancer that
went to the brain so he went up there
and he said as a hero you know I'm gonna
be a role model for others and he got a
drug that blocks that don't eat me
signal that's present on every cancer
cell when cancer cells are born
they've got to don't eat me signal so
the immune system doesn't recognize it
well we now can give a drug that blocks
that and his own immune system was able
to attack his cancer so four months ago
Jimmy Carter said I have no longer on
treatment and I'm cancer-free and so we
have the ability to do that this is
fda-approved four kinds of lung cancer
for kidney cancer four skin cancers for
some cervical cancers we're getting more
and more ways of using the own body's
own immune system to attack cancer at
the same time every patient of mine I
can sequence their cancer and know what
are the on in the off switches and use
what we call molecularly targeted
therapy so for the first time in my
career I walk into a room with a true
sense of optimism based on the
technologies that are happening today
you know another big advance that has
happened has been the field of fertility
and we saw it last month where a woman
you get half the chromosomes for your
father and half from your mother but the
mitochondria in every cell have a couple
chromosomes in them and they come from
the mother only well women and it's not
uncommon have a defect in these
mitochondria can't have children so a
woman in New York City went to her OBGYN
and said I want to have children so the
OBGYN ahur went to Mexico and they took
her egg and they took out her nucleus
and they put it into another woman's egg
that the nucleus was taken out of and
they put the father's sperm together and
a child pregnancy happened so this child
will have three parents right the
mitochondria DNA from the donor the
chromosomes from the mother and the
chromosomes from the father this the
obstetrician and the patient went to
Mexico to do it because it's not clear
whether or not it's legal in the United
States nobody knows we don't have rules
on these kind of things and they don't
want to get in trouble so they went to
Mexico so it really speaks to the fact
that we need governance not just local
but global in the health care field you
know last week in Davos together with
the Gates Foundation we did a simulation
with health ministers around the world
when the next pandemic happens the next
Ebola happens and trying to plan out
because in today's world the world's
flat someone gets sick they get on a
plane they could be anywhere in the
world hours later and so while it's not
cause for
concern at the same time it's cause that
we need global governance these areas to
make sure it's being done right so I
want to end on a point that I think is
critical for health and it's one of the
simplest things but it's one of the most
important and we call regularity so 600
parents they said have your kids go to
bed whenever they want here's a
stopwatch wake them up eight and a half
hours later the other 600 parents I said
have your kids go to bed at the same
time every night and wake up eight and a
half hours later so the same amount of
sleep in both arm one regular one
irregular over twenty percent
improvement in cognitive function the
next day and the kids who went to bed
the same time and got up the same time
we were designed to be regular so people
who graze that is eat whenever they're
hungry grab an apple here a couple
almonds here have 81 percent more
diabetes on a way to just the basis so
our bodies were designed for regularity
we never had a kitchen cabinet till a
hundred years ago so we weren't designed
to just grab food whenever you were
hungry meals were a social function you
got together with the family and now you
had that what the how did they kill you
know you went out in the hunt
you had the leftover in the morning and
that's it so eat your meals the same
time every day you know in Silicon
Valley the better company you are the
more food they serve during the day it's
the opposite you won't work or
productivity work or health short term
and long term same time every day for
meals for when you get up and when you
go to bed and you'll have an impact on
your own performance and so my message
today really is about empowerment it's
that human health is something that we
all have within us and the opportunity
to get we all have to know ourselves
though you know when I was doing the PR
for one of the books I went on a talk
show remotely from Australia and one of
the rules we have a book called short
guide to a long life which is 56 rules
of to do's and not to Do's so in the
middle of the interview the the guy says
you know one of your rules says that you
have to get naked and look at your body
once a month in a mirror I say yes you
have to know your body and your butt I
was going through all that and then they
shift to the other anchor and she's
naked how was that and they had a camera
on my face because apparently nudity is
allowed on Australian television and my
face was shocked and they just wanted to
see the reaction of America into nudity
but I'm a believer that you're each in
charge of your own health in today's
world we have technology where you can
measure anything the notion that you
show up at your doctor at one o'clock
and he or she says your blood pressure
is okay whoever checked in the morning
when you get up at night when you go to
bed when you're pissed off after a phone
call with enough data arrow goes away
and so you are in charge of your own
health and so the reason I write these
books the reason I do CBS News is to
push people in the right direction
because it's an obligation on my side to
educate and teach and really hopefully
together we can achieve a better health
outcome so it's a privilege to be here
today and we're so excited to see the
dedication to the book thank you very
much
and now from the Rancho Mirage writers
festival in California